έχουμε ναι όχι τις επαφές που είχαμε καθημερινής βάσιως τότε που δουλεύμαμε μαζί αλλά με
αφορμή και το γυροκομείο και πολλά άλλα πράγματα που δημιούργης οηλίας πάντα ένα μήνυμα μιαωραία
απαντησούλα μια ωραία έτσι τριβίο μεταξύ μα ές στο μέσα από τασόσακαι τηλέφωνο κάποιε στιγμές
μιλάμε είναι ας άνθρωπος που έχος στην καρδία μου παρούλο που σταμάτησης συ εργασία μα
τα τέσερα χρόνια περίπου κατάλαβες ποτέ για ή τελείωση αυτή στυν εγασια να σου πω
την αλήθεια τα κατάλαβα ποτέ αλλά πάντα μουν είμαι και θα εμε άνθρωπος ο οποίο
στεωυρώ ότι ότι γίνεται για κάποιο λόγο γίνεταιμε αυτής της υπληλοσοφίας θεωρώ ότι κάποιος λόγος
υπήρχει ι να σταματήσει συνεργασίανομε τον ηλία ξεκίνησε τότε μετά τον ηλία η συνεεργασία μεέναν
επιχειρεματία και πολύ ένι σανάλλα πρταύνω πολύ λε είνι έκανες πολλά στην κύπρο γιατί δεν
έφυγε θαπόόμηι να πανστην ελλάδα θεωρίσ ότι η διακοπήτης ε νασιασουμε το ψυνάκι ήταν ο
λόγος να επιστρέψεις πίσω και να μην όχι όχι σίγουρα όχι γιατί διακοπήσης συν εργασία
με τον ιλία τελείως δηλαδή αν ξεκίνησα εγώσισαγωγικά καλιτεχνικά το διοχικιά δεστρία του διόχκιαδ εφτά
σταμά τη σε συνεργασία μου με το ιλία και εγώ το δόδεκα έφυγα από την
κύ από την ελλάδα αυτό δε επηρέασε στον φύγο άλλη λόγι επρέασαν είναι στα σχεδιάσουνα
επιστάτι να νερωτήσεις δεν ξέρω να σου πο πως βρέθηκα στην κύπρου απλά ξεκινώντας με
ωραίες προδιάγραφές σχήματα ψυναυλία στο γάσι πίο πρώτι το παρθαινικό μου βάπτισμα ήταν από το
ρέμο τεγειώνοντας το παινίσει στο κάσει πίς εκος δύο κσπέτεχικιάδες άτωμα γεοργος στεδοφάνους κέςτ στε
συναυλία του αντόνιρεύμου